all right man ble C podcast special
guest here representing AZ we got my guy
Rico band in the building how you doing
man how you doing welcome welcome fresh
out you've been out with four months
four months yeah well welcome home um I
know you got a you've been first of all
feel like you just got right to it as
soon as you touch down I had to yeah
been down too long are you are you going
to stay out I'm staying out cuz you have
had prison sentences impede your musical
career multiple times at this point yeah
that was my second time second time um
and then you for people who don't know
cuz I was talking to glasses Malone
yesterday and I brought up you and then
I was like oh you might know him a sea
Thug he's like oh I know who sea Thug is
yeah it's the homie um yeah so Rico band
is here man you got a new record that's
going crazy on the radio Big Mad L manad
Big Mad L manad you just dropped a new
music video yes sir um is there a
project mixtape album on the way we
doing a project what's I am Arizona
volume 38 I don't know I don't have a
name for it yet for sure when you were
locked up like I'm curious like cuz you
cuz how long were you sitting down uh I
did three years on this so in that
threeyear period there was definitely
like a kind of a a new wave of Arizona
artists were you paying attention to
like any of the new guys like a guy like
mkam who obviously he's been around for
a while but really kind of caught a
caught a serious I didn't know anything
about mkam until I came home got you but
and now I'm paying attention you know
what I'm saying I'm getting up to speak
anybody who you uh who who you're a fan
of that's on the newer side cuz you're
kind of one of the ogs in the in the
scene out there you know what I'm saying
man there a lot of them there's a lot of
people there's a lot of new artists man
it's it's too many anybody you've worked
with or you want to work with um I would
like to work with Markham you know what
I'm saying I do something with him um
there a few females out there that's
that's talented too for sure for sure
shout out to all the females doing their
thing in a man well look go follow uh
this guy he's about to do what he does
what's your IG I am Rico bans with a z
at the end yes sir yes spell it the
right way or the wrong way technically
but it's the right way all right let's
get right to it man Rico band's in the
building bootle C podcast come
on
hey I am Arizona
2o let's
go through it all on the line became a
millionaire Bo with that hustle and my
blood can't buy that anywhere took some
loses on the way the game ain't never
fair these [__] rap about the struggle
I was really there blood stains on my
sneakers my [__] shot right in front of
me picked his body up dropped them off
at the emergency sliding South siding
[__] dying bullets get the flopping
like seals on the island gliding through
the city in the r with no tent [__] your
daddy [__] your mama whoever said I'm a
snitch did my time came home like a real
[__] had to slap a few [__] now y'all
feel a [__] heart frozen headaches
without no pain pills damn she left you
in prison how that pain feels see [__]
shooting up here around they couldn't
take it no more I'm on my knees making
Sal lot with my face to the floow huh
laughing to the bank just withraw the
half a ticket or you calling my phone
now [__] I couldn't get a visit [__]
coming dama dozen Thug and inabana and
all black like I'm John Wick sticked up
like some robber what happened we
supposed to be dogs why ain't heard from
you every time you fell down I was right
there reaching currency murder on my
mind I'm all [__] up my son trying to
be a ganger [__] tough up huh never
seen that man cry sat in Hell doing
Natural Life say B get your life right
you already been here twice smoking on
tree junky C swimming in my liver not
off and some [__] I'll be going till
September Miami dreaming Flawless
diamonds and Cuban links oh you the plug
I'm to Sock It To The Streets lawyer on
standby Jewish graad oh you rather watch
your man's ride smiling faces Snakes in
the Grass open your eyes King same
Circle you fed hate to see you rise King
by polar depression I need a doctor
check myself in dead presidence to my
presence bringing back EV roof again
gambling Taking Chances broke sleep on a
blowup mattress woke up one day CME put
some VPS over my cavities wed by the
fast Marshals invad my people's privacy
running up that for that Mama couldn't
even say goodbye Li to me don't lie to
me you thought I was done save your
apology why lie to me loyalty is rare
[__] it honestly my granny passing I
couldn't make it to a funeral I was
griefing in my C heartbroken she was
beautiful countdown days months getting
shorter hitting burpees on the yard I'm
coming home this summer reminiscing when
I was young thugging on the corner
clutching my glock scraping that PO
smoking marijuana had no guidance all I
knew was drugs and violence ducking
police arus that's on Southern I am
Arizona woo yeah I am Arizona oh man
yeah I am Arizona Rico Benz my
guy came through came through man one
take come on man hey appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll say 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG